ضربات توصف بالموجعه تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه توجيهها في الخطوط الخلفيه
للقوات الروسيه جنوبا
هذا جسر تشونجر الرابط بين القرم وخرسون
وتقول السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان سبب هذه
الحفره في الجسر كان صواريخ من طراز ستورم
شادول بريطانيه الصنع اطلقتها القوات
الاوكرانيه هي الضربه الاولى التي توجه
للجسر منذ بدء الحرب اما اهميته فتاتي من
كونه احد اهم طرق الامداد العسكري الروسي
من القرمي الى جبهات القتال فيرسون وهناك
ركزت القوات الاوكرانيه هجماتها مؤخرا
فيما اطلق عليه اسم الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد
سلطات خيرسون المواليه لروسيا قللت من
اهميه ما وقع بالحديث عن وجود طريقين
اخرين يربطان خرسون بالقرم في اشاره الى
وجود بدائل لطرق الامداد اما توقيت الضربه
فياتي مع حديث وزير الدفاع الروسي عن
تقليص القوات الاوكرانيه عملياتها على خط
المواجهه والعمل على تجميع صفوفها ويتزامن
مع ما قاله الرئيس الاوكراني من ان التقدم
بطيء جنوبا ودون المامول
اذا جسر تشونجر هدف يدخل قائمه الاهداف
الاوكرانيه في معركه الجنوب حيث تسعى لضرب
الخطوط الخلفيه للقوات الروسيه لقلب
معادله المعركه على ما يبدو ففي غضون شهر
واحد تقريبا تحدث الاوكرانيون عن ضربات
لمواقع ومنشات روسيه حيويه مثل استهداف
مقر عسكري روسي في ميناء مدينه بيرج يانسك
وتفجير مستودع ذخيره روسي بمنطقه جنوبيه
خيرسون تمتد الضربات الاوكرانيه وصولا الى
القرم حيث تحدث الروس عن اعتراضهم مؤخرا
لصواريخها ومسيرات اطلقتها القوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه مواقع ومناطق مختلفه في
شبه جزيره القرم وفي الحديث عن هذه
الضربات لابد من الاشاره الى الصواريخ
الغربيه التي تحوزها القوات الاوكرانيه
مثل هاي مارس الامريكيه وستوم شادو
البريطانيه استخدام الصواريخ الغربيه له
خطوط حمر رسمها الروس اذ هدد وزير الدفاع
الروسي ان استهدفت بها الارا ضي الروسيه
او شبه جزيره القرم فان الرد سيكون بضربات
فوريه لمراكز صنع القرار الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]